this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Monday the 13th of
February
the joint is brought to you by manscape
listen manscape already made your balls
nice and fresh it's time to do something
about that [__] face manscape has
just announced a brand new hedge beard
hedge Pro kid they sent me one I don't
have a bid but I did trim and it's
tremendous the bearded gives you 20 hair
cutting lengths all at a turn of a dial
no more changing out attachments and
it's waterproof so you can shave
anywhere and manscape beard and oil
beard Palm will keep you looking
Barbershop fresh and since manscape
wants you to have all the tools for the
job they're throwing in the bid brush
the combo the scissors to make you look
like a million [__] bucks from your
face to your nut sack to your muffler
manscape.com got your [__] get 20
off and free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com and it's Valentine's week
so I'm suggesting you manscape that
[__] jungle down there before you
take Mama out on Thursday on Tuesday
that's 2 30 percent off and free
shipping with code Joey at manscape.com
the manscape beard has your broken the
premier solution to face grooming
and the joint is also brought to you by
after you're looking good and [__] ready
Bluetooth guys shouldn't you always be
at your best 2023 is the year the rabbit
and the year to maximize your
performance in the bedroom Bluetooth is
going to help you get there it's an
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra Cialis but
in chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost just you won and be ready to sling
dick like the soldier that you are I'm
60 and I'm still slinging with Bluetooth
sign up at bluetoo.com consult one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved forget about it
you'll get your prescription within days
and that's when the party starts [__]
it's all online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversation
nobody brow beating me Bluetooth tablets
are made in the USA USA and the Sheep
dis and the ship discreetly nobody will
[__] know not even the mailman that
you're a filter animal if you could
benefit some extra confidence when it's
time to sling dick blue true can help
try Bluetooth for free when using promo
code Joey just pay five dollars for
shipping and Bluetooth it's going to
hook you up go to bluetooth.com go Joey
for your first month Gratis free visit
bluetooth.com for more important safety
information I want to thank Bluetooth
for sponsoring the podcasting for making
Savages out of you [__] let's
get this party started Jack it's Monday
morning
thank you
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Monday
the 13th of [__] February is
Valentine's week so go out today make
sure you buy Mama roses whatever the
[__] you do chocolate whatever they go
for and uh just take it to some nice
place it's also my birthday week
uh [__] Sunday I've turned 60 so the
celebration is starting today that's how
I'm doing I'm not doing dick all week I
did a bunch of [__] last week drove all
over the [__] world this week I'm
just relaxing I'm turning 60 in style
you understand me if I can make it till
60 I'm good I might not be around next
Monday but I just gotta push the
envelope to [__] Sunday [__] I
gotta push it Jack but anyways it was a
great weekend thank God the Super Bowl's
over with the [__] rhetoric and the
[__] you know on Saturdays they're
like hey tomorrow's the Super Bowl
that's great I know this [__] you
haven't stopped talking about it for the
last [__] two weeks what do you
thinking some part of my mind I [__]
forgot but it was a great game I'm happy
uh you enjoyed it you got a [__] nice
time with your family and friends I did
a couple things I went by flooring
things I stopped by the Osteria I went
over my buddies around the corner
it is what it is the 57th Super Bowl
anyway this week some [__] happened that
we're going to talk about uh again we're
going right back to music and life
because this is the [__] that makes my
[__] dick hard let's start the
[__] podcast off this week with the
Grammys last week
The Talk of the Town was uh Madonna
everybody saw that picture of her and
it's uh it's [__] sad you know listen
guys uh
there's a bar around here there's a
couple bars around here on Thursday
nights that are hopping one of them is
the Osteria which I love the food and
cousins which I love the food Astoria I
go to at night because I can sit at the
bar and I go with Vic and we [__]
uh
cousins I usually go in the daytime I
get my salmon with the [__] spinach
and I'm good to go to lunch special
at night those two restaurants become
something else and it's it's great it's
it's [__] awesome the first time I
witnessed it was an ostrich and
um like Thursday nights it's like over
50 night and a bunch of women go down
there and they get dolled up they bust
out the leopard pants the whole [__]
deal and they go down now
listen man they're not none of them are
[__] uh you know gonna [__] break
Beauty records but they're beautiful on
their own little [__] way man you
know I'm a 60 year old guy so when I
look at a 52 year old I'm like [__] she
looks [__] good but even when I was
20 I still remember looking at women and
going wow she looks really [__] good
but I'm going to be completely honest
the first time I went to Osteria on a
Thursday like I think I wanted my
buddies and I saw all these women and
I'm like look at these women on the
[__] hunt and what do they think and
I was doing what everybody else does you
know but I didn't look at the big
[__] picture I didn't look at that
yeah that [__] 55 God bless them
they're still shaving their [__]
they're still [__] doing manicures
and they're going out to test some
[__] guy up that's what it's all
about at the end of the [__] week is
your freedom that's what we all talk
about all the time you know how who the
[__] am I to look at her and go you know
what look at her she's a little out of
place whatever there's guys in the
[__] 10 years older than me with
false teeth on steroids that go to those
places and they're trying to pick up 20
year old chicks is it for me not really
but it works for them again God [__]
bless them last week one of my friends
Athena asked me she goes do you ever go
out at night like the bars and stuff
like that [__] listen
when I was 22 and I'd be in a bar with
my [__] friends and I had girls there
that we grew up we went to high school
with but when I'd be we weren't dating
them or nothing they were just there
with us trying to have a good time but
when I was there with them the 28 year
old guy would come in I'd go look at
[__] Grandpa hitting on young girls
you following me so who the [__] am I to
be this age even the last 20 years I've
stopped going out remember the last six
years uh from 40 on 38 9 on I was doing
coke I don't want to be in no [__]
bar with a bunch of people I can't
[__] hear and [__] so I did Coke at
home or I did Coke in my car I didn't
mingle do you guys think I was out
mingling at [__] clubs in L.A you've
never heard that about me and once I got
off the drugs forget about it [__]
forget about it I have no reason to be
out talking to [__] young people or
trying to be Johnny Goomba hey how you
doing buy him a drink that's never been
who the [__] I am
so even that like I told him she's like
I understand that that it's the truth I
could not listen man I when I used to do
comedy all the time you guys came to
shows you never saw me at the local bar
I love you guys to that
but I'm not going to bother hang out but
Chrysler loves to do it and that gave
him credit for being able to do it I
can't do it guys I I just it's over
so it's really hard for me like I'm
ashamed you know people give me [__] all
the time oh you don't smoke on the
podcast no more why because one day I
looked at one of those videos and go hey
look at all the [__] white hair you
got you should be ashamed of yourself
Joey on [__] YouTube smoking dope
acting like a 20 [__] four-year-old
and when you look at that can you
imagine if I would still be here smoking
pot every [__] day in front of you
guys you're like Joey we get it you
smoke dope great for you you ever go on
Instagram now there's people that have
been smoking dope for 20 years and
they're still smoking dope on Instagram
and after a while you're like
good for you I mean you're still with
this [__] thing you haven't come up
with a new [__] idea in 20 years
you're still thinking because you
smoking camera people gonna like you
more it's fun while you're doing it but
one day you take a look you know people
come with me all the time why are you
not on Tick Tock uh look at my [__]
face
do I belong on [__] Tech talk there's
little kids that put me on Tick Tock and
I love you for it I'm not showing them
trying to get that money I don't give a
[__]
I'm not gonna go on Tick Tock for a
specific reason
so why are you gonna go Joey
you know what I'm saying you overstep
your [__] boundaries why do you think
I'm so embarrassed sometimes about doing
stand-up today with the same stupid
material in the same mentality because
it doesn't look good when you're 55 and
you're going up there talking about
eating girls [__]
so I gotta go up there and talk about
sandals or whatever the [__] it is that
I do with my life at this [__] age
so when you see something like Madonna
dog I told you [__]
that this pandemic did a lot of damage
to people and you're starting to see the
residual damage now and you're going to
hear it in the next two [__] things I
got to talk to you about
for years Madonna's been going off but
this latest thing she's 64 years old I
feel for her listen I love it if she
wants to dance around whatever but
putting your [__] on an nft
63 or whatever the [__] she did I don't
want to see your [__] when you were 28
Madonna look like a bomb in it already
can you imagine a 63 I mean
and I have nothing against Madonna dog
I've been a fan of Madonna since 1980
[__] three Jack first time I heard
physical attraction in a bar or
something like that I went off and then
I moved to Boulder and I went to some
record stop one day and as much as I was
into heavy metal and Aerosmith and Black
Sabbath I bought that [__] Madonna
first time I don't give a [__] what you
[__] think of me that album is
[__] tremendous Lucky Star [__] uh
the best song on the album is burning up
which nobody ever listened to that's the
best [__] Madonna talking about [__]
and [__] and like a virgin come on dog I
won a [__] karaoke contest in 1985 at
a bar in San Francisco because I went up
there and looked in like a virgin
[__] okay and I won first prize
they gave me 50 bucks and [__] uh
50 bucks at a [__] movie or some [__]
like Madonna album no I didn't do the
cones that was Vogue and guess what
[__] guess what [__] in 1991
when I was an open Micah
I went up on stage with the cones I will
make that [__] admission to you I've
never I think I told Lee on a podcast an
old one I went up there with those
Madonna cones and I bombed you know and
I even put Vogue on and did the [__]
thing with the cones on Thug when you're
in Open Mic you you go into Dark Places
see what I'm saying to get a [__]
laugh I didn't know I like Madonna I
[__] love uh into the groove I was
there for [__] uh Desperately Seeking
Susan when I left in July of 85 Madonna
on New York City it was Madonna and
Michael Jackson and every [__] 15
year old girl look like [__] Madonna
okay I love Madonna So for me to be
taught I'm not out of place here I'm
just telling you [__] that we
can't be rough on her
we cannot be rough and pull me down I'll
tell you why because she's [__] lost
it and nothing was more evident than
that listen guys there's nothing
to me
forgive me for these [__] comments
there's nothing more offensive to me
than an old person trying to act Young
listen you have to stay young mentally
to keep pushing that's why I go to jiu
jitsu because I stick around a younger
mentality and I learn from them and
what's going on in the world but for me
to parade myself around with a pair of
[__] jeans and Jordan sneakers and
walk into a place with the sneakers
untied and with a shirt after a while
you'll go Joey
it's time for you to leave I never want
to be asked to leave guys that's
embarrassing I have a choice and I made
a choice growing up that I don't ever
want somebody to tell me when it's only
time to go
ever that's the hardest thing in the
world when I have to go Mike time to go
what the [__] come on take a [__]
hike you know I don't want people to
tell me that
I don't I don't want people to say that
to me
okay
why'd they go through the podcast once a
week not guys for a long time
I was [__] struggling with this
podcast I really was I was lost
I told Mike we're gonna I I was thinking
of [__] cancel it last year like
ending in December because I wasn't
getting through to you guys anymore I
wasn't going anywhere
I had to revamp my thinking take the
podcast to one day a week for motivation
this is what I [__] got but can you
imagine if I came on here every [__]
[__] day
to bust your people's walls about the
same [__] I thought I'm telling you guys
that's why I did what I did when I left
California I restructured everything
it's not because I didn't want to
[__] do it or whatever it's because I
started looking at myself and going
Joey you're getting caught up in [__]
that you you got caught up when you were
40.
at this age now with a child and
whatever I don't want my daughter to
open a [__] Facebook oh whatever and
I'm smoking a [__] joint there I
smoke pot all [__] day I don't need
to do it on [__] video to let you
guys think I'm something I'm not for
months I've been thinking of buying a
[__] car like something that I saved
that money to buy a [__] nice car for
myself I got this Subaru
can't justify the buy guys
can't justify the buy whatever the [__]
I buy I wanted a Mustang I don't even
think I'll fit the [__] monk stand I
think it's too low to the [__] ground
you know
I just don't want to be one of those
people that's imposing them I told my
wife one time I could be a the neighbor
across the streets like you're a
horrible celebrity I'm like first off
I'm not a [__] celebrity but she
wants me to be out at night and like
[__] it
guys I hate that [__]
what am I gonna do with a Mustang what
am I gonna do with a [__] BMW who am
I supposed to be what am I gonna do pull
up at the restaurant and throw my keys
at the valet like something I'm not with
an eye side shirt on that that's guys it
doesn't work for me that's why just
living in that environment used to
[__] drive me crazy it drove me crazy
but Madonna Just I mean the sad thing
about this I don't know if a lot of
people read this her daughter refused to
walk the red carpet with her
why
why because I'm walking down with the
guy from mask she looks like the guy
from [__] mask with a Harry Potter
suit on why what the [__] and listen I'm
listen me and my wife kiss
sometimes me and my wife kiss my
daughter [__] tackles us she's like
stop it when me and my when me and my
wife dance sometimes my my daughter will
turn around and run stop it in public oh
she don't [__] like that don't
[__] do that in public
because she's embarrassed
can you you know could you imagine
[__] showing up with like plastic
surgery I've never understood it guys
a wig
I've never understood it
uh
you trying to fool me with steroids
thinking yeah
I can't do it no more I see right
through it you lose me
you know I could see a football player
that's getting 30 million a year for
tackling [__] gorillas shooting
himself up with steroids but I can't see
a [__] actor shooting himself up with
steroids and we buy into it
we buy into it and then you see a guy
like John Wick that's got no muscles and
he's beating up 20 000 people and
shooting people in the head from an arm
bar position
do you follow me from people when I see
somebody with a wig on I go
you know I don't know he's trying to
[__] [__] me
he's trying to [__] [__] me when
I see somebody when you see somebody
with plastic surgery it looks so [__]
bad now
and in L.A you're like you look at it
and you're like hmm you got to be part
of that cult it's like a little cultiv
you notice that all of them do plastic
surgery all of them look like [__] all
of them know they're gonna look like
[__] and they [__] do it and then
they come back on TV with one eye bigger
than the other two big I mean we know
what you're doing stop it we'd rather
you show up
with what the [__] you look like
just show up and that's what you are but
you know Madonna I love it to death but
don't just give her a break she's trying
to readjust when she was did that
[__] podcast three weeks ago
she did a podcast with Amy Schumer and a
bunch of Hollywood comedians
he asked Amy Schumer
in a video to show her how she licks her
husband's [__]
you're 60. four [__] years old
Madonna
there's a you have so much [__] money
from copyrights and music and [__]
whatever you have so much [__] money
go away into the [__] you know go
away for a while
but it's like they want to linger I
don't guys I like I said I feel insecure
now with this ugly [__] face in gray
hair
going up on stage and doing stupid
[__] jokes I really [__] do I
can't imagine that I can't imagine if I
was still holding on you know I see kids
from my high school still they graduated
50 [__] years ago with a state
champion jacket on
you know that's what they're holding on
to can you imagine if I came on here
every [__] day and talked about the
longest yard that was shot in 2004
or walked around with my [__] Longest
Yard jacket on I put I did a [__]
shirt thing for DraftKings I don't know
if we ever had it right there
like we'll do another one Whatever some
other time but can you imagine if all
have you ever seen the movie something
about Polly then alone no no no
Along Came Polly have you seen that
movie that's a great movie it's
entertaining
and in that movie The junkie the dude
who died from heroin uh the baseball
coach of Moneyball and all that he plays
like one of the actors in the play that
they're doing great actor but it's a
funny story about a guy that did one
thing in Hollywood
and wore it like a badge for 20 years
and he would walk into a room 30 years
later when people didn't remember it and
he would go like oh you know like throw
a scarf and they're like what's up with
this guy he did Jesus Christ Superstar
and he wanted to play Jesus and somebody
else what's the guy's name the actor's
name he played the manager Moneyball he
played the [__] writer and the movie
about music
he played the writer that kept calling
that kid in that [__] movie that he
follows the band on a bus he died of
heroin in New York City a couple years
ago [__] great actor
but that dude that's the character he
plays in there he did a movie 80 years
ago and he's still walking around like
didn't you see that movie dog
that was 20 [__] years ago I don't
know what the [__] you talking about you
got to fix your clock so
[Music]
it's the same it's the same it's the
same principle guys and this is why
I had a great [__] run I had a great
time doing it you know yeah but Joey uh
Burns did comedy through he was 80. yeah
I know oh 99 [__] I would love to do
a uh
a red fox out you know I would love to
do like a not a red fox sound when I
might [__] Roger Waters I would love
to do uh
like a dirty album
like red fox did Wash Your Ass Like That
album by red fox a great album wash your
ass but if you listen to it you're like
he's a 66 7 year old guy doing that
[__] material in a bar like in a jazz
bar things have changed things have
changed you know you could but still if
you know the reasons if you study your
Comics the only reason why [__] red
fox was doing it because he he had tax
problems get tax problems so you could
feel it's a great album you can feel the
material has been a little [__] uh
it was pushed it was sort of like uh my
second album my third album [__] uh
we can't eat [__] with asthma whatever
the [__] it was it was too forced you
know
but I don't want to do that guys that's
not what I want to do is be on Instagram
jumping up and down trying to get you to
shows I just didn't want to do it
anymore it just it didn't look good it
got old for me and for you [__]
people and I just wanted to come up with
something completely [__] different
in my arsenal when I took Comedy Off
when I first moved here it wasn't that I
didn't want to do comedy guys is I
stopped to get my thinking different
I wanted to get away from the sexual
talk I wanted to get from get away from
all that [__] tip
to talk about my new life all that [__]
got old for me really quick
that's why I took the window off but
guess what happened when I got back on
stage I couldn't get away from that
material because that's the material
people want to hear they don't really
want to hear my daughter's [__] I mean
it's cute it's funny but it's not me
getting down and dirty hey guys this
episode is sponsored by better help when
life gets you feeling overwhelmed
working with a therapist can make you
prepared to take on life listen man you
know me I tell you how it is I was
struggling for a while somebody referred
better helping Dana I jumped on listen
better help is tremendous it's a therapy
option that's conveniently convenient
flexible affordable and entirely on the
line you're not driving around you're
not doing nothing just fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
if you don't like at any time for no
additional charge it couldn't be any
easier you'll be live with a therapist
within 48 Hours get on the phone and try
to meet somebody face to face it's not
going to happen this is the fastest way
to empowering your life right now
visit betterhelp.com Diaz today and get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
Diaz better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Diaz a lot of guys
have contacted me lately thanking me for
the service listen I was with him for
close to 10 months and they put me back
on the right track give better help a
shot again go to betterhelp.com Diaz
today and get 10 off your first month
and now back to the podcast if that's
what it takes for me to get out there
and make money I don't want to do it
I want to come out with a new you ever
see
there's a couple Comics now that I see
that took some time off particularly one
and he she came back you know maybe six
or seven months ago
and I see their tweets
and nothing has changed
nothing has changed they're still
talking about the same [__] they were
talking about three years ago only in a
different version I got sick and tired
of rewriting material rewriting my
thoughts it started I needed to come up
with new thoughts new material new [__]
so that's who I am that's why a couple
weeks ago when I was talking about
when I was talking to Bobby Kelly and my
agent and I told my agent that Bobby
Kelly's the next big [__]
thing and he goes yeah Joby you're
selling tickets I got no he said
something he goes you people want to see
you too I go yeah but I don't have
nothing to say Robert Kelly's got
something to say when I feel like I got
something to say I'll be out there again
I'm not doing late shows I'm not getting
on planes but that's what I need to I
needed my mind to change over from what
my mind drugs Coke you know all those
jokes are great they were great they
were great but for me to revamp them and
take them out now I'm not doing you any
justice or me any justice so please
understand where I'm coming from next
thing I want to talk about which is a
[__]
this has bothered me for a long time and
guys listen when I say blue cheese with
wings or go [__] your mother
it's a joke to you guys but it's a way
of life to me
you know when I got out of
this area I saw a lot of things that
bothered me for years with food whatever
what I thought was good what I thought
was bad
um
and what the [__] was I talking about
that's why I don't like it that's why I
don't like doing bunkers yeah like when
I say that [__] guys I stick to it when
I tell people I'm not getting on a plane
because I don't want to get abused I'm
not just saying that I want I don't want
people to think I'm just saying that and
then someday you guys will say well Joey
you went to this place listen I might
have to go to Austin in April or March
or whatever
you still don't want to [__] fly
I don't like getting
[__] abused you know that's a
decision that I [__] make
again I don't even know where I'm
getting with this but I'm very old
fashioned that's why I used to get on
Lee about you're from Boston Lee you
have to eat and and let people know what
you're about you wouldn't eat that [__]
in Boston and that's why when I left New
Jersey there's a lot of [__] I won't eat
and trust me guys a lot of years are
looking at me going Joe you look like
you eat a lot of things yeah but there's
a lot of things I won't [__] eat or
do
I'm the type of guy well I don't want to
[__] do something I just won't
[__] do it
this is how hard and there's certain
things like music music I take like a
[__] Bible movies I take like a
[__] Bible stand up I take like a
[__] Bible but there's a Humanity
around it
when I first started getting into music
I told you guys I'm into anything
anything you play at me there's some
[__] that I listen to like Cheap Trick
do you want to go to heaven tonight it's
okay but I'm not gonna put it on every
[__] day
and
one of those bands that really took me
to a different level was Pink Floyd you
know I'm a fan of Skynyrd I'm a fan of
[__] yes I'm a fan of a lot of the
[__] uh people who led the foundation
for where we are today like uh
Zeppelin the other day I was listening
to Zeppelin I'm like
this is [__] crazy whatever I don't
know what's wrong I was listening to and
I'm like this is crazy at these people
never went on a TV show to promote
themselves they never did so many things
that other people would do they did it
their way they just did it their way and
they didn't like when I see Harry Styles
with a dress on
I'm like Bill bottom is spinning in his
[__] grave these guys were all
[__] sucking putting doing heroin
drinking till eight hours [__] eight
in the morning putting [__] sharks up
chicks [__] and [__] Seattle Led
Zeppelin was living like [__] they
were like Genghis Khan when they were
out there and then you look at 40 years
later you see Harry Styles with a
[__] dress on singing some song at
the [__] Garden you're like what the
[__] has happened to music
what the [__] has happened to [__]
music
you know as a kid I listened to I think
the first listen let's be honest the
first time I was The Dark Side of the
Moon I'd like to tell you I've listened
to Pipers at the Gates of Dawn by Pink
Floyd that's their first album and if
you put it on you're gonna see why that
guy [__] left it's horrible it's
noises and bells and whistles you think
Yoko knows in the [__] neighborhood
all that
all that type of noise and [__] trust me
you get those first couple Pink Floyd
albums
guys not for me I could lie to you and
oh well they're so instrumental like Lou
Reed go [__] yourself it sucks like Lou
Reed I can't stand none of that [__]
music so
after I don't know I I got Dark Side of
the Moon and then I think I got [__]
uh wish you were here a villa all the
Villas when I was in the eighth grade
turn me on and freshman year they were
big on Pink Floyd and I liked them I
liked them on my own but I [__] once
I got introduced to animals done lights
out animals wish you were here dark side
of the [__] Moon the wall lights out
I mean they put out like four or five
albums I love umaguma lights out album
but if you listen to all those albums
yeah they're lyrically great but that
[__] guitar of David Gilmore is is
mind-boggling I just saw something two
days ago I had never seen before I
forget what almonds offered
mind-boggling with David Gilmore was
doing you know people always say well
rate your number one guitarist I don't
have one I don't have one I wish I did
for me I look at David Gilmore Edward
Clapton I see Jimmy Page I like so many
of the Old Timers but I like a lot of
these new [__] geezers too I like a
lot of people but everybody to me serves
a different [__] purpose when I think
about Gilmore it's a bluesy of this out
of the Eric Clapton school it's just
something that I've never heard before
and I fell in love with this [__] man
and I went to see him in 1980 or yeah
1980 and I fell in love with them after
that I couldn't have enough of [__]
Pink Floyd how many acid trips did I
[__] take to Pink Floyd thousands
okay I saw thousands of [__] devils
and horns and blood listening to all
these [__] albums late night with the
earphones on just taking double barrel
sunshine and [__] going to town Jack
I took two hits of double barrel
sunshine when I went to see the wall I
like all that [__] I really respect all
that [__] I have a friend that's traded
in debt that I grew up with kind of is
not like drugs he doesn't like me
talking about drugs
but I'll tell you what [__] this
guy likes Pink Floyd we can talk about
Pink Floyd for hours it shocks me that
he's so straight he likes being floored
anyway
I was
I think what's ruined it for me in a lot
of ways a room there for a lot of people
seeing behind the curtain you know with
everything musically movies but
musically I never saw it behind the
curtain until the internet came
I would just read little blurbs of
magazines here and there and then I
started
seen that the internet became like
Bloodshed was going on YouTube Doug I
could stand there was like two years I
would stay on YouTube till eight in the
[__] morning
just and I I wish I was I was just
watching music
just looking at music music I grew up
with music I listened to I just it
reintroduced me to what the drug culture
did to me you know
I lost out on Pink Floyd I left Pink
Floyd at the door after the walk the
Final Cut whatever I don't know by that
time I was throwing Coke banging people
robbing people I didn't have no time to
listen to oh this is great I didn't have
that time no more life was in front of
me
so the next time I read connected with
Pink Floyd was probably in 2000
and then I started reading these
articles and things that I did not know
about
you know here I was a struggling [__]
comic
and you're going up on stage and I'm
learning from different comics and uh
I'll never forget I worked with a
headliner one time when I was featuring
in Dallas
great headline a guy I looked up to when
I got into the business and the more I
got to meet him in person I [__]
hated his guts and today I just don't
even pay attention to him but I opened
for him at one point I went back there
and I go hey man there's a bunch of
people
out there to see you and he said to me
[__] those [__] I'm not going out
there
and I remember being this feature act
like a guy that wanted to learn and do
better and going
oh my God how [__] disgusting is this
guy
they pay his [__] bills
I mean at that time it wasn't really a
camera Society there was probably like
30 people waiting to take a picture okay
and he flat out was like [__] those
[__]
and I was like Wow and it was just food
for thought so after that years went by
and I was like if I ever get the chance
to talk to people after a show this is
not even picture Bill that it was just
talking to people I go that's that's how
you connect these are the 30 people that
are going to go out and tell 30 people
and the next time you come to town
you're going to have you follow me and
that's how you build an audience guys
and on top of that they talk to you they
tell you what they saw things that you
don't pick up my biggest critics are
people that I've met online or whatever
and they criticize me in a
in a professional manner nobody likes to
be criticized like [__] you dog you know
listen I want you to sat there and I
thought you cursed too much or whatever
years later I I was so blown away by
this comedian I was [__] Blown Away
by it that it stopped making me like him
because who the [__] thinks this way so
and I'm a criminal and I'm a drug addict
and this is 20 years ago so I was really
deep into it at that point and I still
thought about like this [__] guy is a
mutt for doing this
and maybe two years after I read this I
read this story about that I did not
know about
that the reason why Roger Waters wrote
the war the reason why he created the
war was one day in conversation he goes
I really like what I do but I wish I
could build a wall around this while
we're playing so we don't have to see
the audience or ever deal with them
I don't want to deal with these people
and again I was like oh my God you know
I went to see the wall I went to see all
this [__] and then I was like ah Roger
Waters
and then I started reading more and more
about them I saw different articles I
you know I just like Pink Floyd there
was some there was somebody I followed
on Twitter uh David Gilmore fan and I
reached out to him a couple times can
David can you come on the podcast and
he's like this ain't David stupid this
is one of his fans and we run this
and we're looking for donations and
stuff and he had some stuff on Twitter
uh that he had posted
and it was just I'm such a
listen I liked everybody in Pink Floyd
Nick Mason I like them all they each
served a [__] purpose
so now I'm finding out that this [__]
guy is just like
doing everything he can to like distance
himself dad assume
something happened they had a [__] uh
take him to court they took each other
to [__] court and at the same time
I'm learning about sting and all these
other great bands that got taken down by
one [__] [__] that his ego blew the
[__] up so big
you know it's just so big I'm so the
other day I saw something with Stuart
Copeland and I was so [__] happy he's
[__] doing great that guy he's still
you know I think he I just saw a movie
recently where he did the soundtrack for
or some [__]
so you know I kept reading about it and
I got jaded towards [__] David uh
towards
whatever his name is Roger Waters he was
just he was just saying just stupid [__]
you know it's just stupid [__] [__]
and then uh
I don't know
I had the opportunity to go see him
at the time I was making a little money
and it was me Ari and another kid
Hari called me and I'm like yeah I want
to go see Roger Williams was one of
those things like I wasn't thinking
he caught me at an off time and I was
like Absolutely I'll go see Roger Waters
how much are the tickets
and they're like well they're like 300
280 225 and I'm like
for some reason after I committed to it
couple days later I'm like I really
don't want to go see this guy
this guy's a [__] [__] I don't
really want to go see this guy
first of all it ain't Pink Floyd without
[__] David Gilmore in my world that
ain't Pink Floyd without David Gilmore
listen and I give breaks to people like
it wasn't Black Sabbath without Ozzy but
when [__] Dio came in there heaven in
hell was a great [__] album so I had
a I had to shut my [__] mouth
but this [__] guy just I don't know I
take I take that [__] so [__]
seriously like I took their work so
seriously the way I did Nirvana's the
way I did [__] Led Zeppelin the way I
did early Aussie I did I looked at work
and I go that's [__] great work
and that's four [__] guys okay
regardless of what you say yeah Randy
Rhoads took it to the next level but
Ozzy was the Statesman in that [__]
band when they were young kids him and
Rudy were young kids
so when all this [__] started going on
about you know him trashing Gilmore and
Gilmore kept it together for years man
good morning and say dick I think the
one guy died from Pink Floyd over the
years I think there's three original
members left
and
what [__] got me a little off and you
guys are gonna
when Ari called me to do that I even got
acid
and for some reason I didn't want to
cancel on re so what I said to him was
I'm going but I'm only taking 200 cash
with me
if I can't find the ticket for 200 I'm
not going in there
and on the acid we took the train down
there we went down there and dog we
couldn't find a ticket for less than two
hundred dollars
and I was just fine with it we ended up
going to a place named Phillips and we
got the French dip we we were eating
while we were tripping it was [__]
tremendous then we went back to my house
and watched some movie and that was the
end of it and I was like thank God I
didn't go against my word and go see
this [__] guy and then
maybe a year ago one of my friends the
guy I told you about called me up and he
goes hey man he's at the Garden do you
want to go and at first I was bored you
know I was like
I'll do anything at this point you know
I'll go see any [__] body again I was
like I'll go see anybody but I'm not
going to see that [__] I just
it's not for me I'm not gonna go see him
in there and talk [__] and then I was
following him on Instagram and I was
watching like his rehearsals and his
show
for somebody to act this way there's one
thing I could deal with anything guys I
could deal with
you being a junkie I could deal with you
robbing my weed I could deal with a lot
of things I'll tell you what I can't
deal with
before and now that I left La even more
than I can't deal with ego
I don't like ego I do not there is
nothing you could do to justify your
treatment of people or you talking to
people that way or your snobby [__]
attitude unless you're [__] Jesus or
you [__] I don't I don't know who the
[__] you think you are so every time I
see ego I'm done I'm done and I see it
right away something about the word
something about the way you got out of
your car I'm done I don't need this [__]
and
it's an ego that [__]
not for nothing you had David Gilmore on
the other side of you that's a
combination where I come from that's a
pair that's like that's like Jimmy Page
and [__] Robert Plant that's like
Mick and Keith they do everything
together all those lyrics they look at
the guitars you know
for you to say this [__] at this point
listening to the work that David Gilmore
did how [__] dare you
done about a year ago maybe nine months
ago he was in Austin and he went on the
Rogan podcast and listened those guys
except for Tony Hinchcliffe aren't
[__] pink floyders they're not
[__] people I saw the wall on double
barrel Sunshine there was no way I was
going to see any Pink Floyd concert
without [__] hallucinogenics in my
[__] system to the last degree why
disrespect the brand you know what I'm
saying you're gonna go see Pink Floyd
you're gonna take a one-hitter go [__]
yourself stay at home go and get the
full effect of that [__] you
gotta take mushrooms take some sillies
chocolate I don't give a [__] what you
gotta take
I took the I'm a [__] the real deal
guys I went there and sat outside and
talked to people you know tailgating for
the wall was a [__] tremendous people
were saying oh they need Jews in the
theater tonight put them up against the
wall it was [__] crazy out there
people were tripping on acid it was
[__] insane
dead down there you know when I call her
already called the next morning he spent
the night with him and he was great and
the whole thing and it was great and I
saw some of the podcasts and I enjoyed I
didn't see the whole podcast
but the guy still what the [__] he is
you know what I'm saying the guy still
what he is so last Monday I don't know
if you guys saw it his David Gilmore's
wife who was a Lyricist who actually
wrote music
the [__] Pink Floyd she knows these
[__] I guess David Gilmore did
an interview in Germany
and he just went off on the United
States and Israel and now the United
States is responsible for
Roger Waters I'm sorry I'm so thank you
for the correction and David Gilmore his
wife saw it and [__] tore him up
called him a misogynistic egomaniac
[__] tax avoiding [__] just
everything that she could call him and
then David Gilmore retweeted it and
wrote [__] he's on she's 100 correct
so now there's a [__] war going on
over there at pink floydville but the
the thing that really hit me in the head
and Mike and I discussed it as we were
setting up today
this [__] went and re-recorded
one of the greatest albums of all time
not some Mickey Mouse Taylor Swift um
not some Mickey Mouse Harry Styles um I
mean an album that's life-changing do
you understand me Dark Side of the Moon
was the number one album for [__]
years for years it probably lost the
crown two years ago to Drake or
something like this who the [__] knows
but they had the crown for years it's
like a few [__] that don't know
so Stairway to Heaven was the number one
requested song for 30 [__] years
straight now they're like we can't play
it no more we're done we can't but for
30 [__] years Dark Side of the Moon
carried the exact same [__] clout now
this [__] scumbag went and redid Dark
Side of the Moon with [__] no Gilmore
no Mason the other guy's Dead who I
don't [__] know right right yeah
right Rick right [__] uh well Rick
writes a guitarist from The Comedy Store
anyway he was a comic great guy Rick
Wright he used to go in there late night
The Comedy Store and play Mike [__]
whatever would wrap over his guitar it
was tremendous
but uh now he's gonna tape over the dark
side of the [__] Moon
this guy never stops this is like
you know and listen like I was telling
Mike maybe I come to Mike and go Mike we
were in the band together it was a
couple things I didn't like about
Dockside at moon since it's the 50th
Anniversary let's redo it hoping the
whole brand take it out on the [__]
road let's do it that I wouldn't be
matter but you think you're better than
David Gilmore [__]
that's not [__] wet on my [__]
world so guess what I'm I [__] Roger
Waters I don't give a [__] about that
[__] [__] that punk ass [__]
because how can you do that
how can you even I saw all those
[__] that went to those
concerts to see him on tour last year
you should be [__] ashamed of
yourselves should be [__] ashamed of
yourself supporting that [__]
and giving that guy another reason to
tap himself on the back and go home to
tell him something to remember how
[__] great he is that's what you do
when you go support that [__]
Nazi [__]
that tax paying [__] how do you
like that one
[Music]
that's a big accusation you [__]
anti-tax [__] sucker but hey what are
you gonna do
that's another week in a [__]
beautiful [__] lives guys
and now you know why I do the things
that I do and half the [__] that I don't
want to [__] do
you know Madonna's gonna be Madonna and
Roger Waters is going to be [__]
Roger Waters
both of them have their own [__]
faults but I think Roger Waters is just
he needs to be shot hung put under the
[__] jail and poor Madonna she just
needs somebody to talk to her and say
it's over
it's overcome she's putting a tour out
now this year she's 64 years old
it's going to be a ton of lip syncing a
ton of [__] you know
I like is she I would love it I will
[__] love it that's what she needs
somebody strong in front of her so she
doesn't have to do that much time at 64.
she's not gonna dance like she used to
you know she could try I mean [__]
Mick Jagger does a great [__] job
with it but
yeah Mick Jagger works it though you
don't see Mick out making Tick Tock
videos do you you know why because Mick
Jag is somewhere getting his dick sucked
you don't see Mick Jagger on Tick Tock
do you you don't see none of those guys
like that what's that Tick Tock whatever
the [__] it's called the Chinese app you
know
guys just see the world for what the
[__] it is I do they can't pull the wool
over my eyes anymore I just see it and
go what the [__] are these idiots doing
but anyway that's another fun-filled
[__] Monday motivation podcast from
myself that's why that's why I cut it to
once a week
and in the future when I get this
[__] coconut going up again I don't
feel like I'm wasting your time I'll do
10 [__] podcasts a week when I have
something to say these last two or three
weeks I've had something to say I'm
making a slow comeback into who the [__]
I was I'm excited about the book uh
today I think chaz's podcast is coming
out the jazz is and I did salamina's
podcast last week I don't know how to
pronounce it that's all coming out this
week trying to promote the book and
that's it guys I'm just excited about
[__] turning 60 this week I never
ever thought this day would come
honestly I never ever thought about this
day because I had more important things
to think about
but I'm happy that uh we made it we did
something with our lives man I'm [__]
ready to die I'm like Biggie Smalls now
I'm ready to die if you think I want to
be walking around with a [__] uh bag
[__] and pissing you got another thing
coming but that's not I'm just worried
about I'm just looking forward to this
week guys and uh that's it and that's
that I love you [__] with all
my heart stay black
and I'm lurking [__] I'm in the
neighborhood I'll keep you guys posted
and I'll see you guys next Monday or
next Tuesday I don't know if we're gonna
put it out on my birthday but maybe we
will I'll see you [__] next
Monday tip top Magoo stay black Uncle
Joey's loves you and have a great week
all right I want to thank you guys for
supporting the podcast today Lima Donna
alone it's all gonna work out the joint
is brought to you by Blue chew blue shoe
is the online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra Cialis
but in chewable tablets at a practice of
the cost one shoe and you'll be ready to
go I love Bluetooth they're great I've
been working with them for years and
I'll tell you what they send you those
individually wrapped you put them in
your little secret pocket and once you
bump into somebody who's willing able
and ready to rock your world you're done
and remember it's all online no visits
to the doctor's office no walk with
conversations if you could benefit from
extra confidence time to sling dick
Bluetooth going to help you out and they
will try blue true for free what are you
talking free using promo code Joey just
pay a fin for shipping that's five
dollars for you Gentiles that want to
swing to the dark side
bluetooth.com which code Joey for your
first month free visit bluetooth.com for
more important safety information and
thank blue shoe for continuing
sponsoring The Joint the joint is also
you brought to you by manscape manscape
has a new brand new beard hedger broken
the beard hedger gives you 20 haircut
lengths all that'll turn it down you
gotta change no attachment it's
waterproof and you can shave anywhere
including the shower and manscapes bean
oil beard Palm tremendous will keep you
looking Barbershop fresh zoom and since
manscape wants you to have all the tools
for the job they're throwing in a beard
brunch comb scissors to make you look
like a million bucks get 20 three
percent off and free shipping with code
Joey at manscape.com again 20 off and
free shipping with code Joey j-o-e-y at
manscape.com the manscape beard had your
pro kit the premier solution to face
grooming the joint is also brought to
you by better help better help is a
therapy option that's convenient
flexible and affordable online and it's
all online just fill out a brief
questionnaire you're going to get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you're gonna love it if you have a
problem with that therapist you can
switch them anytime for no additional
charge it couldn't be any easier so if
you want to live a more empowered life
and have control over your thoughts
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com DS I want to
thank better help I want to thank
manscape and I want to thank blue shoe
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys have a great week and I'll see you
[__] next Monday tip top Magoo
[Music]